jeune homme 26 ans travaillant six jours
sur sept chers jeunes filles pour passer
le septième jour ensemble rapport sexuel
soit c'est une drague d'un autre temps
celui des petites annonces dans la
presse dès la fin du 19e siècle
le figaro est l'un des premiers journaux
a lancé ces annonces matrimoniales le
chercheur français suivra juste après et
dans les années 70 c'est le quotidien
libération qui se met à la page 38 ans
brun aux yeux clairs chan drôle cherche
adorable petite folle pour rendre folle
y aura un avenir possible brune très
minces comme de personnalité derrière un
tempérament se cache une grande douceur
sensibilité il reste une place dans ma
gaspin bill pour une nana na na voulant
balader dans l'arrière-pays aller
partout le jour et la nuit
le tout avec make bout et intelligent un
mode de rencontre qui reflète
l'évolution de notre société
isolement dans les campagnes qui
persistent puis dans les lilas partir
des années soixante dix mots qui
reviennent du mot clé à des mots qui
reviennent sans arrêt solitude
communication
contact discussions la télévision aussi
s'amuse de ces annonces matrimoniales à
l'image de l'humoriste anne marie
carrière en 1978 jeune fille 52 ans mais
féminine propriétaire des f2 à tourcoing
cherche complice spirituel et fougueux
ou de l'animateur philippe bouvard un
peu lourd dans l'émission passé donc me
voir en 1981 jeune femme 31 ans
célibataire recherche jeunes filles ou
jeunes femmes
mais le run cooking jeune femme
recherche d'une femme autre façon de
trouver son âme soeur passer son annonce
directement devant la caméra
en témoigne cet homme dans l'émission
chéri sur antenne 2 attention séquence
kitschissime à souhait la femme de ma
vie je compte la trouver là elle a entre
20 et 30 ans elle a le sens du dialogue
elle est cultivée elle est douce mais
avec du caractère
elle adore les enfants et elle est très
belle et bien foutu aujourd'hui ces
petites annonces résiste mais elle peine
à exister face aux sites et autres
applications de rencontre